verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
besuchte am donnerstag die salzburger
pioniere wichtige eine dem
österreichischen bundesheeres person
katastrophenschutz und spezialisiert in
person darin hochgebirgs lagen auch und
wir werden in dem bereich der pioniere
100 millionen euro investieren
da wird natürlich insbesondere auch in
salzburg hier sehr viele sachen kommen
weil es auch notwendig ist gerät
anzuschaffen
bestes beispiel für die wichtigkeit
dieser anschaffungen ist der
brückeneinsturz im salzburgerischen
rußbach vergangenes jahr
salzburgs pioniere stellen innerhalb
einer woche die für die bevölkerung
wichtige verbindung mit einer
ersatzbrücke wieder mehr mitgenommen
habe ist wie gut und perfekte
zusammenarbeit in diesem von ihnen
angesprochenen fall aber auch darüber
hinaus funktioniert die miteinander
lande bundesheer zivile organisationen
lassen sich dann auch schwere
situationen bewältigen